in the 70 years since the
schuman declaration crises and
challenges are not unknown to europe
in many ways the motto of europe
has always been not only united
in diversity but also united
in adversity is  today in this
period of adversity and in response to
this crisis europe needs more than ever
unity of determination
and ambition and it is in this spirit that
the commission is working on a
recovery plan  ambitious for europe as
you ask in your resolution
today 1 3 to 10 bis down in
europe nor on the sly includes on you
is us darwin and de na loba jet jasta
as I do not propose a cough and hymn to
the  nhtsa date reflect akram value8
makana them to protect the wolfman
dsb automne sa cité
no designed for de fioutch fruits
aux rita vnv this challenge for each of
kings coronavirus league europa
as for chris to return mustapha from
venice was a teenage life in the
fan vote  stones steinsson house is
niet multichances a notice montmagny
modern and out and the wolf of tea banh
dilemma this conclave organizations
generation dragons of asia castle in
bobigny but another between the
fanciulla in drug of the sni am young
but klitschko osk lines lifesite here
fell  of 6 and of valtice g strings of
past contours of young and narration
inside of acadie-bathurst in the europa league
tao of gab vaccinate english europa
language the fjord long
live europe